really let's just get down to brass
tacks and I really loved one student's
commentaries of saying why do we keep
talking about future problems with
climate change when it is today and
that's so right we have climate change
effects right now it is today it is real
beautiful question how effective is
protesting in changing climate policy
and I thought maybe that's a good place
to start this wrap-up part of my lecture
we're going to do what we've been doing
the last few weeks I and John will be Co
guest lectures if you will will will
roam through some slides pretty quickly
and then we'll get into panel format and
you can ask us questions and I have the
pre questions that you sent but how
effective is it and really the North
Dakota access pipeline is really a
beautiful example isn't it if it went
from something that wasn't in the media
at all in fact it looked like it was
actually actively squelched to where bus
loads of veterans were showing up to
help help out the protesters and you
know an effect has been had at least
stopping some actions at least for a
while
and we certainly all know silent
acquiescence will not help anything so
you know it sometimes it gets tempting
to just go dark but don't it won't help
anything but I know for myself I'm not
much of a protester I see where I add my
value to this particular situation as
playing to my strengths which is
teaching and working on engineering
solution so that's my path but if you're
inclined to be a protester I can't tell
you much about how to make that work but
it does seem to have its effectiveness
for sure again I love I love the end of
this book next next year should we be
teaching this again this will this will
also be a required text along with cold
cash cool climate atmosphere of hope by
Tim Flannery and you've now seen this
every week because I love this and
because it really has resonated with you
I'm seeing in your notes so it real
is you know we have the tools and we
really could do it if we had the
political and civil will to do it and
right now it's up to us you is us it is
we we really have to do something about
this and we can and the race for a
better future we can make that choice
and we've talked about what's what's
critical here we started out saying
science is critical to let us know what
the situation is policy drives change
engineering brings solutions that's
where we've been focused but as we've
gone through the quarter we've seen
various lectures from startups and
funders and you know solving impossible
problems and we've seen well we need a
whole lot of other things too right
the right market the right business
model pivot figure it out
funding design thinking going to the end
of what does the solution have to be and
then working your way back to how would
I get there collaborations remember to
protect your IP and your financials
remember we started flexure one with
some things that Illustrated how dire
the situation is and part of how we got
there right back in the I think it was
yeah 60s when this ran an oil company
was proud remember we thought we were
going into the next Ice Age proud that
they could supply enough energy to melt
7 million tons of glacier and they were
right this is one time when advertising
hyperbole it was actually true but we're
worried about sea level rise we
certainly are we should be and the costs
are huge
the jet stream shift which has come
about you know in fair part perhaps
perhaps mainly driven by the ice melt in
the Arctic changing our weather changing
droughts changing how cold things get
horrific storms and remember this this
is these two slides that I'm going to
spend a minute or two on is why we
should never quit there was one question
and I think it's from somebody who would
never actually give up but it's like
okay it's bad why don't we just quit and
the reason is that every single degree
is worth fighting over if you're hearing
people saying well we're never going to
make the two degree limits so
it's all over that is so wrong and
remember with policy we have much much
more of a chance according to these MIT
projections of being at two and a half
degrees C or lower than we do with no
policy where it looks like we have a
half 50-50 chance of being above five
degrees C why does that matter because
there is a world of difference when
you're up around four to five degrees C
extinction of more than 40% of known
species when you're down around one
degree C you know a little less we're
saying an increased risk for 20 to 30%
of known species it's just every degree
that you these are from the IPCC 2007
conclusions that terry root and a
graphic artist put together to
illustrate this remember every degree is
worth fighting over and fighting for so
please for heaven's sake don't give up
but this is how I felt when I first got
it right oh the truck is coming the
children are dying I'm in trouble
and and it was paralyzing right but if
we can take positive action really
positive action well recent positive
action that helps a lot and so to roam
through the first lecture just to review
that so I and our minook Ehrman's gave
an intro and talked about geoengineering
and I have to put in the word there of
things are pretty dire for hitting the
right targets of temperature rise given
the speed with which sustainable
solutions are not being adopted let's
put it that way it's slow right and so
we're thinking if you want to do
something to accelerate your ability to
cope with these changes and maybe
moderate some of the effects maybe
geoengineering but make sure they're
well characterized they won't do any
harm they'll be reversible preferably
localized with localized impacts that
you can understand and that
geoengineering will not I loved that a
lot of you picked this up in your
summary won't fix the root cause
problems but it may give us less damage
while the world gets to where the world
needs to get with long
term solutions for sustainable and you
know geoengineering isn't a new thought
this is back in 1976 and there was this
public law enacted by the Senate and
House of Representatives that
weather-related disasters and hazards
including droughts hurricanes tornadoes
blah blah blah result in a lot of
suffering and therefore weather
modification technology has significant
potential they were really they were
thinking in what may have been more bold
than wise ways but they were thinking
about this back then which is really
interesting the other thing I would say
is that there were a couple of really
good questions why not keep to you
engineering work quiet so people don't
count on it frankly that's what I did
the first several years when I was
working on this it's like if if people
got wind that there might be an out then
we just keep on the same path that we
are and we get into worse trouble
because as your moderating some of the
effects as geoengineering will you're
not fixing the root problem and it just
makes it you can back things up away as
Steve Schneider told me when I first
presented this to him and Terry root you
can back it up a little way but it's not
going to go back by the same path it's
kind of put unanticipated pressures on
everything so side so you don't want to
have geoengineering be the solution and
let's keep on with you know our SUVs and
and you know 10 miles a gallon and such
but if you keep it quiet at this point
where it looks like some of it may
really be needed you don't want it to be
in the dark and somebody suddenly says
okay I've got the solution here it is
and they put it out there in the world
without any chance for public scrutiny
it's got to be it's got to be
scrutinized people have to have a chance
to weigh in on what are the problems the
possible problems what are the pros and
cons if you are bold enough to think
that your solution may may have less
risks than some other solutions it seems
to me it's your duty to get that out
there there may be this other choice
that you might not be aware of so that
people can weigh the right actions the
right choices with all of the
information available and it's really
hard to get funding if it's secret so
it's really so I think it's a lovely
question and I
went that way at first thinking yeah I'm
not sure it'll work and he I don't want
to be the excuse but at this point I
don't think that's the right choice and
then the back again to the should we
give all up all help hope now no of
course not there's a world of difference
between how dire things will feel and be
between one two three four or five
degrees C okay so what I decided to take
on as you know is slowing down the melt
of the polar ice caps and I think I have
neglected to show you the 34 second
video of how this how this works how the
ice melt goes I would rather give you
the more up-to-date one if it's still up
here this is a really good illustration
so here's recent picture of what on
earth does this mean remember we've got
bright ice melting multi-year highly
reflective ice melting open ocean
absorbing sunlight much better than and
almost no area in the summer to reflect
sunlight anymore but what does that mean
really I mean this is satellite imagery
what does that mean and it means that
that's a world of difference isn't it
you've got a few chunks of bright
multi-year ice and you've got some very
thin ice starting to form and I'll show
you our photos from Barrow a few more of
what the ocean really looked like and
these were the predictions back in 2007
before we fell off the cliff in 2012 and
are falling off even farther 2016 we are
record low ice extent for this time of
year and remember it's a feedback effect
when I started this that was twenty
percent of global temperature rise now
it's a third and so we have the simple
mission and strategy to just use these
materials that reflect sunlight our
Weddell allow evaporative cooling to try
to slow ice melt by reflecting I'm
assuming most of you have seen this by
having something that we can control so
that we can take care of it if we've
overcorrected and we can argue over
what's just right and we've been and and
so that the technique then is we we
float something or we put it on young
ice and we reflect sunlight that's very
so over here we're
selectively material reflecting sunlight
preserving ice and snow or conserving
water same tricks and we've been doing
field work because you can theorize
about this all you want but until you're
out in the field testing at prototyping
failing fast forward all the things you
hear about a start-up pivoting quickly
until you're in the field and testing it
you don't really know what's going to go
right and wrong we have learned a lot
we're operating as a non-profit because
saving the Arctic doesn't turn out to be
a very good business model so far in
Barrow just a few weeks ago in November
this is what the ocean looked like
hardly frozen and as one of my
colleagues typifies this this was like
looking at a slushy beginning to freeze
up a little bit you could see the water
getting a little bit thicker but it was
still certainly not ice and it was
having chunks come gradually into Shore
to build up a very unstable bit of ice
and a few chunks out there farther away
but it really this was an interesting
trip that way there I am right with my
Cal hat forgiving you you really it
wasn't as cold as it should have been I
did borrow one finally but yeah that's
my ski jacket and there we were in the
hangar just getting you know it's all
about engineering details if what you're
trying to do is get the data to be able
to prove your technology out and
demonstrate it and be able to feed it in
models and be able to show the world
what the pluses and minuses are there is
so much instrumentation you have to do
there's Satish who you may remember
guest lecturing with us
there are Oh Satish and I think one of
the Inupiat Eskimo native Native
Americans who were helping us out there
which is required up there here's what
the young ice that had just formed on
this Lake looked like as opposed to snow
right young ice is very very dark here
we were just scraping it around getting
things set in so that we could set our
buoy up what a nice hole look
as soon as we we drilled through it
wasn't very thick lots of water and then
just what it's like to do this at a time
of year when it's two hours of sunlight
they say two hours of daylight but what
they don't tell you is this incredible
twilight colors for hours and hours on
either side of it there's part of our
team there again oh yeah with some of
our he was acting as our polar bear
guard this time too we didn't see a
polar bear and you know it's it's big
out there you think you're doing
something and you're in the tiny speck
in this past space at this point and
there was our our buoy one of our data
buoys that I said set up and then we've
been in Minnesota where we've been doing
testing for years because we are in his
backyard and he is really handy with
tools and really passionate about this
project and what we were doing here was
and with one of the same co-workers from
the Arctic what we were doing here was
segmenting the pond so that we can get
as good data as possible with another
colleague we just you know you gotta
just work so hard to get it right and it
always seems to go in too dark and so
that's that's what the real on the
ground on the in the field things that
we're doing are and I have to say
frankly it's fun to when you're working
with something that you are really
passionate about and that you think can
make a real difference you have a
surprising amount of fun while you're
getting little sleep and a little bit
right it's actually pretty great and I
wanted to I've got just two more slides
here I think I wanted to say that we in
this room share a set of superpowers
that may not be obvious to you as you
wonder if you should give up we've all
got education intelligence perseverance
we care John started to go through the
rest of the list you know diligence we
know how to follow right you could name
the virtues that you know that you have
by virtue of being here or by virtue of
caring enough to be watching this online
and so if not us who's going to take
this on and if not now when
right I know that's not original with me
but it's very relevant so I wanted to
say before I close
this isn't quite the quite the order I
thought I had I wanted to say as we went
through the quarter we went through many
talks that touched on policy which is
critically important and startups and
John's book is all about right than many
entrepreneurial ways you're going to
fail forward and figure things out
get them figured up of course if we said
funding we'd have the same thing with
another couple solving impossible
problems there's more and what I wanted
to ask you all in just a lightening
round if you guys will dare to speak out
somebody anybody on each of these lines
say one thing you learned because I know
from your summaries you've learned a lot
so what did you learn from the first one
this can go quick if you just blurt it
out anybody seriously cool we could have
the same person on the next paper what
about the trip to the water recycle
plant a lot of you really loved that
wasn't that cool they were saying that
they could warn the clinic about
oncoming need for for medicine because
you could tell in advance of when a flu
epidemic was coming yeah wild huh
what about Brent Constance CEO to mental
mineralization what about the Tesla
co-founders Marc and Martin what did you
learn that could help you in your
entrepreneurial endeavors for the rich
[Music]
yeah they did that because they knew why
every other one had failed and it was
just every other TV company had failed
because they didn't do that right learn
from other people Doug and Satish are
polar instrumentals and explorers
bipolar is that the truth what about
Julio sorry yes Julio and
and then the Phantom Kate unfortunately
couldn't make it she she she really
wanted to be here what did you learn
from there oh Sagan who can actually be
really clean in importance here you sure
yeah wasn't that interesting
yeah thanks Nancy and Rex show me the
money
the idea of that profit only comes at
the expense of social good isn't it
not sure beautifully played yes isn't
that nice
what about Kimberly take it on the
impossible tasks
well what I learned from Kimberly I've
got to say was this the studies on what
makes a good leader I found really
interesting forward-looking inspiring
vision honest you know really outweighed
I don't think messy handwriting which is
my own being even made the list
something anybody would care about right
it was how do you actually lead people
and do you guys remember that the secret
for words that you say to somebody to
actually begin to let brainstorming
occur interesting and tell me more
yeah and how that just opened up the
conversation and the possibilities and I
loved reading your write-ups where you
were saying I didn't think we could
possibly do this but then we started at
the end you know and vision the solution
and then we started and I'm convinced
now we could yes yes what about just
last week
Rocco David and Deepti anybody what's
going to help you go forward in your
entrepreneurial endeavors or your lives
oh please it's the last one I'm asking
you
LBL Ricky laughing yeah yeah that was
quite incredible wasn't it and these
guys are so super I mean Rocco and David
they're super powers collaboration and
here they found one more that's just
working for them to to pull this out in
the world hopefully you will have
something very inspiring that you're
learning from dr. Kumi this is my very
last line and it's saying really I I put
this class together with the hope that
it's going to help you learn how to
pursue and implement really good ideas
and projects to help with climate change
and you're gonna have course evaluation
forms to fill out and please do fill
them out it'll let me know it'll let
Stanford know how we did with this okay
so thank you and now we're gonna turn it
over to John do you want me to try to
get your slides opening
all right okay so I'm told I have 20
minutes so I might cheat and take a
little more than that but we'll see
Leslie asked that I review some of the
motivation for understanding this
problem and then talk mostly about
entrepreneurial challenges and where I
think the opportunities lie for people
who want to make a difference
in the space a lot of this will be
review so I'll go quickly we know from
the Academy National Academy of Sciences
and all the IPCC reports that the earth
is warming humans are responsible
one of the biggest forcing agents for
warming is of course emissions of carbon
dioxide and this shows you the fossil
fuel century this is starting in 1850
showing fossil fuels land use change and
cement the net contributions to carbon
emissions over time so exponential
growth for much of that period that
growth in emissions has led to a huge
jump in co2 concentrations from fossil
fuels and land use changes and this is
plotting the last 800,000 years of
carbon dioxide concentration so they
take the bubbles in the ice cores and
they can actually trace back and measure
just how much co2 there was you see that
there's this range between about 180 and
about I think the highest is about 300
parts per million by volume over the
last 800,000 years but in the last
century plus we've pushed the Earth's
atmosphere well outside the comfortable
range in which humanity developed and
civilization was created and this is
really an unprecedented change as you
can see in the last 800,000 years here's
the last 12,000 years and you see
relatively stable concentrations of co2
in the atmosphere yes
so humans modern humans I don't know
what I don't think anyone knows exactly
but I think it's around a hundred
thousand years ago okay so in terms of
civilization
you know the first parts of civilization
that we're able to identify ten twelve
thousand years right so we've had a
period of remarkable climate stability
over this as best we can tell from our
measurements and here's what we've done
tear carbon dioxide concentrations as
you've probably seen from the news that
now we're just over 400 parts per
million at 405 I think something it goes
up and down during the course of the
year but this is a pretty substantial
shift out of that comfortable
temperature range here's what happens
when you start putting more greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere so this is a
reconstruction of temperatures using
proxy methods and direct measurements
over the last 12,000 years and
relatively stable temperatures but then
you see this jump as we approach the
modern time now we know everyone thinks
that you know these changes they seem
small one Celsius - Celsius that's 1.8
Fahrenheit per degree Celsius degree the
reason why this is a concern is because
of the distribution of temperatures what
you're doing when you raise the
temperature is not just changing an
average you're shifting the distribution
so what we used to think of as extreme
hot weather or hot weather can occur
many times more frequently as you shift
the distribution even a small amount and
that's the source of concern the the
extremes that come about from these
shifts come about because we're shifting
the distribution over now there's
actually data on this Hanson did this
number of years ago and you can see the
distributions plotted for the northern
hemisphere over a set of period so 1951
- 81 as a baseline 81 - 91 91 - 2001 and
2001 to 2011 and what you see from this
is not
is the distribution shifting but it's
it's flattening and spreading so those
extremes that you see in temperature as
well as precipitation are coming about
broadly across the world this is not
this is something that we can measure
and it's something that's worrying so
the damages that come from changes in
climate are not primarily focused on the
average change but focus on the extreme
changes now if that weren't worrying
enough this is what happens if we don't
do anything so I relied in the book on
an O policy case that MIT did in 2009
this shows what would happen if you
followed that no policy case over time
to 2100 in terms of the concentration so
you saw we had this big jump in the last
12,000 years but we're talking about a
very much larger increase in the
concentrations by 2100 so over 900 parts
per million co2 now of course co2 is not
the only greenhouse gas so in the MIT
scenario they included other gases and
what they showed in there no policy case
was an increase in the carbon dioxide
equivalent concentration by 2100 of over
1300 parts per million it's about four
point eight times pre-industrial
concentration so it's more than two
doublings of greenhouse gas
concentrations in that very very short
period yes so here's the here's the
breakdown carbon dioxide methane nitrous
oxide and then other gases and warming
agents and this doubling I put it in
terms of I put in terms of a doubling
and the reason why we do that is because
the climatologists traditionally measure
the sensitivity of the climate to
warming by thinking about how much the
climate will warm for a doubling of
carbon dioxide or greenhouse gas
concentrations
so one doubling typically would result
in an equilibrium temperature change of
about three Celsius if you have two
doublings or more then you're talking
about
five or six Celsius and that's a very
substantial shift in temperatures so
this is what that means using that same
historical data but then applying the
temperature changes from the MIT study
and of course this is not the
equilibrium temperature change because a
hundred years isn't long enough to have
all of those changes manifest so we're
talking about at least six Celsius
beyond pre-industrial times and that's
not even including some of the the
feedbacks related to melting ice faster
than we thought we would and and so on
so it's a huge huge problem and
civilization I don't think can survive
six Celsius I think it is there's no way
that this because we depend on so much
of these life support systems I you know
people will still survive some creatures
will survive but it will be a disaster
now people who have been working on this
for a long time have tried to find safe
boundaries and the thing that's been
talked about a lot is the two Celsius
warming limit most of the more recent
work shows that even that is probably
not completely safe but as Lesley said
two is better than three and three is
better than four so the best we can do
is to get that keep the temperature as
low as we possibly can yeah there may be
there are these tipping points that can
come so there's a lot of potential
dangers here there's a guy named
Weitzman at Harvard who has done a bunch
of work on what he calls the long tails
of risk the tipping points the things
that might lead to big disasters and the
models that the economists use basically
ignore that and he tried to he's an
economist he tried to include that in
his analysis so one of the realities
though that people need to understand is
that fossil fuel scarcity will not save
us even if you believe in peak oil which
I do not it's not going to help us and
the reason is that there are so many
fossil fuels on the earth that even if
we burn a small fraction of them we will
destroy the climate so I show here the
fossil resource base based on the
the global energy assessment in 2012
that's everything that we know exists
and think exists the conventional
resource base doesn't include some of
the things like methane hydrates and
other more exotic fossil fuels and then
I show what's called proven fossil
reserves those are the reserves that we
can we believe we can extract using
current technology at current prices so
those are pretty well known and you can
see the no policy case only burns the
proven fossil reserves in a tiny part of
the fossil resource base so fossil fuel
constraints will not save us from this
problem so what the heck are we here to
do always have to have a Calvin and
Hobbes cartoon in here critically
important ok so as John Holdren who was
my professor at Berkeley years ago likes
to say we have three options in dealing
with climate we can adapt we can suffer
and we can mitigate to adapt means that
we make human systems more resilient and
flexible suffering means accepting what
comes but what comes is likely to be
extremely costly for humans and the
environment mitigation is what I focus
on mostly because the more mitigation
you do the less adapting and suffering
you need to do we're going to do all
some of all of these three things the
more mitigation we do the less
adaptation and suffering will do so the
questions always come about mitigation
options how much carbon will they save
how much will they cost are they
feasible you've all probably seen this
curve this is kind of the standard curve
in economics benefits and costs for
reducing emissions the avoided
incremental damage costs fall as you
move towards reductions of impacts the
abatement costs rise as you move towards
zero emissions and there's a point where
they cross which is a so-called least
cost optimist is kind of the standard
approach the problem is that this
approach assumes that we can actually
calculate what the cost of these options
are or
cost of damages are twenty thirty forty
fifty years from now and that is just
wrong
we cannot do it there's no way to
predict these things if you review the
the forecasting literature as I and
other colleagues have done you see we
haven't been able to do it in the past
but there are very good fundamental
reasons to believe that we can't do that
we cannot predict the future with
accuracy economic systems are different
than physical systems physical systems
have structural constancy economic
systems do not so this conventional
model of doing the full benefit cost
analysis figuring out what that optimal
point is and then taking action is
completely inadequate for dealing with
this problem
instead we need to start thinking in an
evolutionary frame we need to understand
path dependence need to understand that
there is actually no such thing as an
optimal path but there are a lot of
possible paths that we could take we
can't plan or know everything about
those paths but we can use that warming
limit whether it's one and a half or two
C as a way to define success and then
decide whether we're acting fast enough
to be able to solve this problem so one
of the fundamental realizations when you
realize the world is path dependent is
that our choices now affect our options
later so the things we do now in terms
of deployment will allow us to learn and
reduce costs and accelerate emissions
reductions so this curve the standard
curve that the economists use it assumes
constant or decreasing returns to scale
so you don't have economies of scale you
don't have learning effects but in the
real world learning effects are
pervasive that's one of the main drivers
of path dependence so learning effects
are our friends in this now to survive
in this environment to do well in it you
need to invest in a lot of different
options you need to fail fast fail
forward fast I'm going to use that
that's really good
modify your plans dynamically learn as
fast as we can this is what the National
Research Council calls iterative risk
management when you can't actually
predict with accuracy you need to act
see what happens and then change what
you're doing if it's not working so the
warming limit you've heard about
defining that warming limit
one-and-a-half 4qc of pre-industrial
times figure out how much we can emit to
stay under that limit define the
pathways that meet that constraint it
turns out those pathways are pretty
tightly constrained at this point we've
dilly-dallied for so long that we don't
have a whole lot of options here and
then we need to figure out what we need
to do to achieve that pathway
how many power plants do we need to
build what rate of improvement in energy
efficiency do we need and so on and then
we try things we fail fast than we alter
course as needed now this is a picture
of what happens when you wait and there
are some foolish people who argue that
we should wait and see your Lomborg is
among those kind of people the problem
is that with this problem you're
dominated by cumulative emissions so if
you wait what you're doing is locking in
infrastructure and you're locking in
damages and you're if you wait you're
going to have to reduce emissions even
faster later so there's no benefit if
we've technologies and energy moves as
fast as computers maybe there'd be some
logic to this but they don't so it's
just a moot point the more you wait the
harder it's going to be and the more
infrastructure you build the harder it's
going to be if you build them and
they're generating profits politically
it's even harder to to turn them off
it's easier to stop them before you
build them so there's no time to waste
the cumulative emissions are the area
under these different curves and it just
makes the problem harder the longer you
wait so working towards this limit is
like strategic planning for big
companies it's not forecasting and the
people who work in big companies they
know you can't do this kind of
forecasting but you need to say I'm
going to build a plant that's this big
and produce this much by this state and
they figure out what they need to do to
get there so this is a way of organizing
our thinking about solutions to the
problem now this is a similar graph to
the resource graph that I showed you the
fossil
for a space compared to proven reserves
go to the new policy case the safer
climate case which gives us about a 2/3
chance of hitting the 2c limit means we
have to keep even the majority of proven
fossil reserves in the ground or you
have to figure out a way to safely store
the emissions from burning those fuels
so it's a very substantial challenge so
let me turn to some of the lessons for
entrepreneurs that was kind of like
drinking from a firehose I apologize but
it's important for motivating the
urgency of tackling this problem so one
of the first lessons that you learn
about when you start to focus on this is
to think not about energy but about
tasks to understand what people are
doing with energy and then to figure out
new ways to do the same thing using a
lot less energy and if you think about a
material that's made of some calcium and
some other things that's very hard you
can make that in a furnace that's a very
high energy thing or you could feed a
chicken and the chicken will make the
eggshell for you at room temperature so
you get the same end result of this
immensely hard material but doing it in
a very different way if you think about
the task you might come up with that
idea or use it copying the the way the
chicken does it but if you think about
an energy system and say well my job is
to make that furnace more efficient
you're going to be constrained because
you might be able to make it 10% 20%
more efficient but if you totally
rethink the process from the ground up
by thinking about the whole system you
can make dramatic breakthroughs another
important lesson is that time is money
and one of the things in modern
societies that you find as particularly
as you get older as you have kids is
that time is probably the most important
thing you have and as you get wealthier
you're willing to pay to give yourself
more time and the problem is that if you
try to focus on just energy
you're going to I think in many cases
you're going to end up at a dead end so
a lot of people I I've worked on a
startup that was attempting to to give
advice to homeowners about energy and we
had what I thought was a good business
model and we ended up developing a
recommendation engine analyzing people's
options and so on for residential
customers we were about three weeks from
getting acquired by Google we had the
this was like 2008 right so around the
bad time of the financial crisis and we
had I think cracked the code for this
but the hard thing about it is that you
when you're dealing with very small
dollar numbers for the energy use in
households it's very hard to make a
business out of that and so that's
something you need to think about is
where's the money and one of the things
that where the money is is in people's
time and rich people's willingness to
pay and you know middle-class people's
willingness to pay to give them a little
more time with their family and that
turns out that time is something is much
more valuable to people than your modest
expenditures on fuel for heating your
house because it's really not a whole
lot of money another lesson that comes
from thinking deeply about economic
models and systems is that property
rights turn out to be a key leverage
point so in all those economic models
where they talk about how hard it's
going to be to reduce emissions they
hold property rights constant so that
means that there's no innovation in the
way property rights are defined so
here's an example of how property rights
can change the game so when people
defined water rights and mineral rights
for different countries they said okay
we're going to split off the mineral
rights so when you buy land you you
actually you may or may not be buying
the mineral rights under that land you
may or may not be buying the water
rights those are separable things
well what they've started to do and Jane
Woodward has been a great innovator in
this is to take the rights to the wind
above certain
and and sell that off as a separate
thing and so what that means is that it
allows people to get capital and this is
happening in the farming communities a
great deal now it allows people to get
capital to build wind turbines and give
money to those farmers but before they
define those rights it was a lot harder
to get the financing to do it another
example is for battery-powered devices
like this one in the olden days you were
when you bought it you were responsible
for disposing of that battery when it
was done but in Europe and some other
places they've started to do what's
called extended producer responsibility
they've said ok you manufacturers you're
responsible for bringing that battery
back and getting it recycled so in
essence they they're selling the battery
but the manufacturers are still forced
to hold on to the property rights in the
disposal of the battery so again this is
an innovation in property rights that
can change the game and all those
economic models that talk about how hard
it is to do something about emissions
they just assume that there's no
innovation in property rights which is
absolutely wrong it's not something that
we're going to be doing a whole lot more
of that stuff
now I particularly am interested in
focusing on information technology for
data collection substituting bits for
atoms so if you can you know instead of
sending yourself overseas you use video
conferencing using smarts instead of
parts so substituting an electric
vehicle you're getting smarter about
what parts you're using what parts
you're not using redesigning systems so
you don't need to use certain parts and
then using IT to transform institutions
to make them a whole lot more efficient
in all of this were working forward
toward goals so same thing like with the
2c limit we figure out what we need to
do to get to that goal the same thing is
for any of these innovations that you
want to think about you need to think
about ok here's the goal I want to get
to how am I going to get there and
building up a business case that will
allow you to get there so
for whole systems it's important to
think about every part and in the early
days when we did these studies of
emissions reductions we almost always
took the business-as-usual case
projections of how much natural gas
would be consumed how much oil would be
consumed how much electricity would be
consumed then we we pretty much kept
those constant and within electricity we
figured out how you could be more
efficient or how you could shift the
generation of that electricity but
what's happened in the last five years
is that some people are realizing that
if you look at the whole system and
start to shift some of the uses towards
electricity where we have a lot more
options for reducing emissions on the
generation side you can actually achieve
much greater reduction so by looking at
the at the whole system you can make a
huge difference this the the scenarios
here you see III is this deep
decarbonisation scenarios those involve
a lot of this electrification whereas
the renewable energy futures projection
from NREL the reinventing fire case from
RMI that's pretty much status quo
business as usual sort of projection so
electrification can have a huge effect
so here's something near and dear to my
heart we did some work on the historical
trends and efficiency of computing first
published this work in 2011 what we
found was that the energy efficiency of
computing at peak output doubled every
year and a half from 1940s to about 2000
and that's about a hundred fold
improvement every decade it basically
enabled the smartphone in your pocket it
pushed us into this really interesting
new design space since 2000
the trend has has actually slowed so
we're now at about doubling every 2.6
years but it turns out there's
innovations on standby and low-power
modes that actually are accelerating
beyond what the peak outputs so here's
this is a fun calculation I did taking
those trends projecting them out and
comparing them to a theoretical
calculator
that Fineman did back in 1985 he said
well let's assume a three atom
transistor here's where you get to and
that would place us at the limit in
about twenty forty two twenty forty one
sorry and that was just his thought
experiment but that researchers at
Purdue the University not the chicken
company found and the University of New
South Wales had already created a
reliable one atom transistors so there's
potential for moving well beyond this
but right now the interesting thing is
focusing on ways to improve the standby
and off power for these devices because
we're limited by the physics of our
current devices at peak output so peak
output is and everything but idle is
turns out to be pretty important now why
do I care about these efficiency trans
well they enable all sorts of cool
innovations so here's the big belly
trash compactor and most of you have
probably seen these what they do is they
have a photovoltaic panel on top they
have a very simple communication
technology that sends a signal that says
I'm full and then the trucks can decide
how to do their routing every day based
on which one is full or which one is
two-thirds full so it sends a text
message so very low amount of data but a
very high value use of data and what
you're doing then is allows you to
optimize the routing so instead of
always going to every can you could just
go to the cans that are full and that so
what you're doing is you're substituting
bits for atoms you're thinking about
what you need to do and using
information a tiny amount of information
to generate the same service but at much
lower environmental cost now these
trends have also led to incredibly low
power sensors so my friend Josh Smith
the University of Washington has created
a device that uses 60 micro watts on
average and that device can actually
scavenge enough power from radio and TV
signals of its within 5 or 10 kilometers
of a big TV tower to operate so that
allows you then to
operate continuously without any other
source of power so that's an example of
how getting into this new design space
then allows you opportunities to do
things that you couldn't otherwise do
and there's there's even fun things that
are related to medical devices there's a
company that creates a pill that you it
actually has it has no battery it has a
cathode and an anode you put it in your
in your your stomach and then when it
gets to your stomach the stomach acid
acids are the electrolyte and it sends a
tiny signal to the patch on your skin
that says I took the pill at this time
now eventually you could imagine and
having other sensors but the point is
that there's no battery there's no the
way it's created it's basically this
food product it's got some it might have
some copper and some other things but
but it basically goes in your stomach
sends a signal it turns out to be pretty
important for certain patient
populations did they take their medicine
or not oh we know because it has been
measured so it opens up all sorts of
possibilities there's another one from
the University of Michigan very tiny
very low power in this case they're
using it to measure tumors so again you
don't need to measure it every second or
even every minute you can do it so that
it measures at every 15 minutes or every
hour and if it's a fast growing tumor
you that's all you need and so again
this opens up the possibility of truly
personalized medicine but you couldn't
do it without these improvements in the
efficiency of devices so here's Street
Line networks there are other companies
that do this as well but these are
little motes that are installed in
parking spaces that actually say are you
in the is there someone in the parking
space or not and it allows you then to
to tell where a parking space might be
because one of the big energy users for
transportation is people driving around
looking for parking
now the tote sorry good
link's when I was going through Berkeley
sensor and actuator center for my grad
school and this is the kind of stuff
that we worry about in our buoys our
data bullies out there in the field is
how can we have with the lowest power
and getting our information out so it's
really interesting to see you looping
back to that and the field now so so
another interesting thing about this is
that the total power needed to do this
total electricity is is really small so
for forty thousand parking spots in LA
though they don't have all that coverage
yet but if you just extrapolate it to
forty thousand spots the total power for
all of those moats would be 15 watts so
this tiny amount of electricity
relatively small amounts of data can
allow you them to optimize this much
larger system of cars driving around so
tons many many hundreds or thousands of
tons of cars is being affected by a very
tiny amount of electricity a very small
number of these notes okay so I can
summarize sorry I've taken half an hour
instead of 20 minutes but that was a lot
okay so one of the things you learn when
you talk to folks who work in businesses
that they they already know that you
can't predict the future
they don't have this hubris that the
modelers have that you can somehow do
that this idea of working forward toward
a goal that we'd use for the warming
limit is also applicable to any other
big strategic problem that businesses
face the focus in this world where
you're not trying to achieve optimality
because you realize that's a false hope
is to focus on risk reduction on
experimentation on evaluation on
innovation and cost-effectiveness not on
knowing the optimal path in advance so
this is what we call iterative risk
management now the science when we first
started looking into this question of
the 2c limit the science really pointed
to that limit it said you know in the
last you know
several hundred thousand years this is
the hottest that it has been and the ice
has been stable and we haven't had major
extremes ultimately though the choice
that people make about whether that
limit is the right one or whether it
should be one and a half C is a
political choice it's a value choice
like all choices now in this case we're
we're declaring this value judgement
upfront we're saying the 2c limit or the
one-and-a-half C limit that's what we're
shooting for and we're going to do our
best to get there we may not get there
but we're gonna do our best to get there
if you accept that that way of looking
at this problem is valid and if that
limit is the one that you want to focus
on then you have to have very rapid
reductions and you have to keep most
fossil fuels in the ground even if
there's some carbon sequestration and
storage still most fossil fuels have to
stay in the ground and that's something
that I think most of the politicians and
people in the more status-quo world
haven't really come to grips with yet
they really do not understand it and you
saw it actually Trudeau who's I think a
you know pretty decent guy overall in
Canada he said something like I can't
think of an example where a country that
had all these fossil fuel reserves
wouldn't develop them and you think
about that for a second you realize he
doesn't get it because you're right
that's exactly the problem and you can't
do it right you cannot develop all these
reserves most of them have to stay in
the ground and that's that that's what's
called the collective action problem you
can't fix the problem
individually any one country or group
you know any one large country or group
of countries can by themselves destroy
the climate so that's why you have to
coordinate that's why you have to work
together to constrain this but I think
there's still there's a real inability
of the political folks to get their head
around this because they really really
really really do not want to fight the
fossil fuel industry they keep looking
desperately for ways not to have the
conversation with the fossil fuel
industry that says you have to keep most
of your reserves in the ground they
don't want to have that conversation
because we're dealing with what may be
the most powerful industry in the world
in cold cash cool climate there's an
appendix where I tallied what the
revenue is from the fossil fuel industry
so oil and gas coal five trillion
dollars every year for comparison Global
tobacco five hundred billion so ten
times bigger than the tobacco industry
so that's what we're dealing with here
and that I think the politicians are
really scared but at the end of the day
physics doesn't care about the
politicians physics doesn't care who we
elected president physics doesn't care
about any of that all I cares about is
how much greenhouse gases how many green
a guy we house gases have you put in the
atmosphere because that's what's going
to determine the temperature of the
climate so we can't just wait there's no
such thing as wait and see with this
problem we are done I started working on
this problem in the late 1980s we did
the first comprehensive analysis of a to
see warming limit in 1989 so this is not
new information the issue is how do we
create the will to make these rapid
reductions and the important thing as an
entrepreneur to think about is that you
don't have to care about the status quo
you don't have to care about that five
trillion dollar revenue from the fossil
fuel industry your job is to make that
number go to zero that's what your goal
is so that's why you have to look you
have to use whole system design you have
to look for improvements that are not
twenty percent better but a factor of
ten better or a hundred and so that's
the that's the kind of shift that you
need to go go have in your brain you
need to start thinking about how can I
make a big difference how can I really
change the game and because you're not
in a big company you don't have to worry
about those revenues going away your job
is to make those revenues go away for
that for that company so another
important insight of course is that we
need to learn but the only way you learn
one of the one of the most powerful ways
to learn I should say is that
you'll learn by doing and you only learn
by doing if you do and that's why you
need to implement that's why you need to
deploy technologies as fast as we
possibly can we have a lot of options
and that's something again that I think
is very poorly understood most we can we
can achieve very substantial reductions
80 plus percent using on the shelf
technology we're still going to have to
learn some things some Rd will
absolutely be helpful but we are at the
stage where we can do that it's been
true for a while the question is whether
we'll decide to do that and I'll leave
you with that one I'll leave you with
this one which is the best way to
predict the future is to invent it LMK
[Music]
will want to grab some more refreshments
to help fuel their questions please do
and it's interesting being a panel of
two so ah what was the best one that we
wanted to say from here what yeah I like
this one
what part of the climate solution are
you most excited about in terms of
entrepreneurship innovation and scaling
in the next 10 years
let came out in the in the presentation
I'm I think information technology has a
huge role to play in this because it
leverage allows us to leverage small
amounts of information to affect big
flows of energy big flows of materials
and if it's applied in the right way it
can actually have huge impact on the way
the economy uses resources and generates
emissions yeah yeah and that was a
beautiful thing of saving so many miles
of cars driving around by telling where
where the parking spots where are they
no even these little moats they're about
I know they fit in your hand
they're pretty tiny they can have a huge
effect yeah yeah that's that's so funny
I mean that that's that's the other
thing I work on it's MEMS
microelectromechanical
right there are there burning questions
from here because we've we've answered
some of these if we've gone along but
for instance auditors never have a
chance to submit their questions we've
got any burning questions before we go
back to these ok we're answering at all
I love this one if you were to start
over at Stanford as a student where
would you focus your time and energy and
studies and why and I'll say for myself
I would have taken some business classes
and I've had to learn it all on on the
ground you know boots on the ground and
that would have been awfully handy
because it turns out entrepreneurial
solutions do seem to be the ones to go
after yes so that's one of the things
about entrepreneurship too is that it is
inherently interdisciplinary so if
you're just taking classes in
engineering I think you're missing the
boat and I love engineering it's great
fun but there are business classes there
are classes in earth systems there are
all sorts of different ways to expand
your mind and expand your skills and you
can learn then how to work with other
people because I think one of the most
valuable things in business is to
understand how to work with people from
a completely different discipline and
communicate with them so that I came
from the energy resources group at that
University that's like over at Berkeley
over there and that was my grad graduate
work and I Kate the energy resource
group is an interdisciplinary program
it's one of the very few I per is now
you know one of another one that's very
well known but but that's a pretty rare
thing if you're in engineering you're
gonna need to seek out those
opportunities to communicate with other
people in business in you know software
engineering if you're not doing that
materials whatever else you want to have
the ability to work with many different
kinds of people and then you'll be
successful at whatever you do
extended career question but I'm
actually gonna struggle to price as the
question was it's more of a worry but
you know we learned in the class fund
the VC industry is horribly set up for
for clean tech because it's so capital
intense you had a longer term yeah and
you know a lot of good companies have
failed and so that this the problem is
so urgent my my worry is like you know
you could as a student right out of
Stanford go join us startup start your
own thing but you're probably going to
fail and so the chance of having an
impact is measured in terms of Colton s
clothes or emissions reduced is what is
on a risk-adjusted basis versus I should
you join a medium-sized company or
utility or the United States government
like work you know how do you think
about that kind of where can you
personally have emotional impact yeah so
I think part of it is deciding the kind
of problem that you're good at solving
and I agree that the startup space is
really risky most of them fail it's just
that's the nature of things right and so
you have to figure out a way that you
can use your skills to get the highest
impact and in a medium-sized company its
multi medium sized company that is
growing rapidly that can be a pretty
good place to make a huge difference
because they don't have time to worry
about whether you have every single
skill that you need to do something
they're just going to say we need
someone to do this you're smart go do
that and so the small to medium
companies are also already generating
revenue right and so that so
sustainability is not just about
emission sustainability is actually
about profits too because if you're not
generating profits you can't continue
right so that's another kind of lesson
from the business world and it's
important to understand that just
creating something that is low emissions
is not enough you need to figure out a
way that people will see so much of
even that that they will give you money
for it you have to create a business
model for it and I think that a lot of
people I get a lot of people coming to
me and saying oh I have this great idea
for you know measuring power use in data
centers or you know whatever so that's
an example where that's great but you
know the real problems in data centers
are not about technology or measurement
they're about institutions they're about
having separate budgets for facilities
and IT if you don't fix that it doesn't
matter how good your technology is so so
I think part of it is having a deep
understanding of where the value is and
then finding companies that get that and
that you have skills that you can help
them get that and so I I would you know
it's if you're able to do a start-up and
you think it's exciting that's something
you should you should try but and you
will learn a lot you will learn a lot
but I would you know I would make sure
you really understand that business
model and and believe that the dollar
flows that they're going after are large
enough and that the institutional issues
that might impede you capturing some of
those dollar flows are small enough
retractable enough that you can actually
fix it I just think there's a lot of
people who underestimate they think they
have a good technology maybe they even
have a great technology but if they
haven't figured out how to get people to
pay for it it's gonna die so that's what
I think the main thing is figure out the
business model make sure it makes sense
to you make sure that the VAT like it's
very hard in the residential space
because the money flows for energy or
tiny people don't care when you're
you've gotta get the kids to school you
don't have time to worry about twenty
bucks over the course of a year on your
utility bill and so that's I think
that's where I see the most people
saying oh look at this we can measure
how much electricity your refrigerator
uses okay but that's not where the money
is
yes and we've had some great examples in
here of companies they kept pivoting
until they found a business model that
worked I meana
that is that is a challenge Oh rarely do
they start with the business model that
works all right yeah they kind of figure
it out yeah yeah you're definitely gonna
figure it out as you go along your book
is a collection of scientifically based
advice for entrepreneurs looking to
solve the climate problem can you talk a
little bit about your own experiences as
an entrepreneur in this space have you
done your own startups basically and and
when did things go exactly right and
then did you have more hope for Humanity
regarding this crisis well you can never
give up hope
thanks Bree with that thank you so the
thing about startups is that most of
them fail so I told you about wot bot
that was the one that almost got taken
over by Google and that was you that
like that and then I actually have been
advising litte motors which is a company
that has designed and developed
technology for a two-wheeled what they
call an auto cycle which is an enclosed
motorcycle two wheels uses gyroscopes to
stabilize so that if it gets hit by a
car at skids and so they have prototype
they have all this all these patents
they've gone a long way to getting to a
technology that will work but you know
takes the next step once you've gotten
there is you need tens of millions of
dollars to do real polished prototype
and so that's that's often a big hurdle
for these kind of things and so whether
we get there I don't know yet but it's
you know it's been a great experience
working with that team because they're
doing something that no one's ever tried
to do before and so you always learn
something but you kind of have to expect
that you're not going to succeed most of
the time and if you're not if your
personality is not resilient in the face
of failure either fix that or figure out
something else to do because somebody
wanted to ask me what I think is the
most promising avenue of solutions to
the climate problem to pursue and push
for in the policy space right now
and in 10 and 20 years I am an engineer
I'm not a policy guy but you're not even
a guy what are you talking about
generically I'm spending but I really
take to heart some of the comments that
were from our guest lectures earlier in
this quarter about when you specify a
specific policy I think this was about
Evie's electric cars right that if
you're saying oh it's going to have to
be this kind that you can get it wrong
and you can set things back I think this
was about a biofuels discussion if
you're asking the the central you know
the the US government or any other
governmental body to say which
technology is going to have the most
positive effect on the climate they
might not get it right I mean it's it's
certainly obvious that that one should
drive towards reducing co2 and methane
emissions at that part great but
specifying a technology I'm not sure but
you're right add to that yeah please
because there's actually experience in
this you hear always people saying oh we
don't want to pick winners but there's
experience in actually setting standards
that don't pick winners so they have
these standards for energy efficiency of
devices and those standards they develop
a test procedure and then they say
here's how we measure efficiency and
then we say we're gonna set a standard
that says efficiency has to be this much
or better and the manufacturers then
have to figure out what technologies
they will apply to get that efficiency
or better so you're not picking winners
you're setting a performance level and
that's the kind of thing that I think
government is uniquely suited to do and
for the appliance standards and for the
standards for automobiles they have a
cost-benefit test where they say you
know we're gonna look at the
technologies that we now know about and
then we're going to try to set the
standard in a way that is feasible based
on what we know almost always what
happens though is that the industry is
smarter they figure out a way to do it
better in
cheaper and faster than what the initial
Opry ory estimates indicated and that's
something that's a kind of general
lesson from this literature is that
people are smart and innovative and they
learn how to do stuff and policy I will
say maybe this was directed to me
because of my frustration years ago
about getting let out of gasoline and
it's like why did the EPA cave after we
had it ready to get to market you know
but then if the if the standard changes
if the standard gets relaxed the
companies won't introduce it so yeah if
you set the standard to leniently then
companies who have even better solutions
aren't going to get them right there
right and what happens over time for the
appliance centers is that they update
them there's a periodic update schedule
that's in the legislation that's sorry
each time the technology changes so they
get a whole lot better and so when they
first did the the air conditioner
standards I think they set the the
energy efficiency ratio at 10 or 12 and
now they're up to 18 or 20 because
technology has gotten an industry can
probably count on then that it's going
to get more exactly so so having the
expectations set accurately I think is
good and then perfect you end up with
people and institutions being smarter
than what we thought initially so while
we're talking about government what role
do you see government funding playing in
supporting for-profit energy and
environmental adventures what
governmental challenges to such ventures
do you foresee with the upcoming
administration change I would say focus
on the state level yes because they're
gonna be states that will not stop
California is among California Oregon
Washington New York Massachusetts there
will be you know continued updates the
renewable portfolio standards and that's
going to create issues and there's
probably I assume California is going to
go back and say we want to have our
automobile if they try to relax the
federal standards I bet California will
go back and say well it's our right to
set our own standards so we're gonna do
that and that has led to these periodic
cycles where the state says we want to
do that and the manufacturers say well
we don't want to have California which
is this huge portion of
or market different than the u.s. please
give us national standards so that's
happened several times that is fantastic
well if it works we'll see how do you
square the need to invest in a broad
range of options fail fast learn fast
with the reality that many of the
entities that need to act this way are
slow-moving conservative national
governments and multinational
corporations not Silicon Valley startups
you have to make them obsolete you
basically that this is the thing your
job is to make fossil fuel companies
obsolete so in the olden days people
fought wars over salt because salt was
the only way to preserve meat Tom man
but when refrigeration was invented the
demand for salt really went away right
always I mean or at least it fell such
that you know you didn't need to be so
concerned about it we can buy it for $1
in the supermarket so the goal is to
turn fossil fuels into salt use
technology and institutional innovation
to make people look at this dirty mucky
stuff and say well that's great for
making petrochemicals because we're
still gonna need to do that even after
we're done with emitting fossil fuels
but it's really not something we want to
be messing around with it means we need
to make combustion obsolete so that's as
entrepreneurs that's your job is to make
those fossil fuel companies obsolete if
you encounter someone who doesn't
believe that climate change exists or
that it's anthropogenic what's the
single strongest piece of evidence that
you refer them to for me it's the 34
second video of doom that failed to come
up there the ice melt over season it's
if you didn't if I haven't shown it in
class before it hit ok I did and it's on
earth ice no people believe weird things
25% there's a National Academy of
Sciences survey 25% of the people said
that the Sun goes around the earth in
the United States
so do I really want to be arguing with
these people not those people well but I
think that the most if you encounter
people who are coming at you with a lot
of arguments there's a great website
called skeptical science which lists it
actually tracks the arguments so people
send in things saying oh I saw this
argument here and it gets tally oh and
so then they list all the peer-reviewed
responses to those arguments and you can
see the earth isn't warming and hasn't
warmed since 98 all those other
fallacies all listed there so that's an
important resource skeptical science and
then the other thing to say is that
we've known about climate change since
the mid eighteen hundreds people that
they figured out that gases with three
atoms have this warming effect that's
just how it is that's the quantum
mechanical fact and so that means that
you know people started measuring it
Tyndall and some of these other folks in
the mid 1800s 4ei first actually
speculated about it in 1820 right so
this effect is that we've postulated and
now measured from multiple different
independent sources is based on some of
the most well-established principles in
physical science and I just want to say
to them you know well I'm gonna take
away your cell phone because you you
can't you know this wouldn't work if the
physical science wasn't working so you
know you have to pick your battles you
have to decide whether it's really worth
arguing with certain people but you know
at this point I think only the cranks I
think these people are cranks the people
who are the people who actually you know
claim to be quote-unquote skeptics at
this point they're cranks I think
there's some honest confusion out there
too I'm gonna take you to your least
favorite question how much are you
willing to sacrifice to end climate
change at what point do we as a species
give up and accept the end my answer is
never
battle over every degree well so what
gives you the right to give up
who said you can give up if something
you can do now will save even one life
in five years or ten years or a hundred
years then you should do it and you know
what four degrees is better than five
degrees and three degrees is better than
four degrees and at this point we have
actually we don't know how well we can
do I think we haven't even tried and
you've already seen what happens over
time is that people are smart and once
we set a goal we figure out a way to get
there so I just think we have no right
to give up and I feel strongly that
there are enough options that we can
still fix this problem with minimal
disruption of human society there's
still going to be damage there's no
escape at this point but but I think
we're we're certainly at a stage where
we have a lot of options and if we
decide we can fix this problem
you